apology tour if you will that this had
been said online there was all of the
criticism there was advertisers leaving
we talked to Bob I I hope they stop you
hope uh don't advertise you don't want
them to advertise
no if somebody's going to try to
Blackmail me with advertising blackmail
me with money go
yourself yes just like nervous laughter
look at
Zid go yourself ah
is he doing it okay wasar the first oh
you calling him out hey Bob wow bober
spoke earlier that day bober yeah you
think he's still in the room actually
when he's saying this how do you think
then
about absolutely amazing when he's like
I hope they stop you can he actually
Freez St advertising he actually freezes
for a second so so Andrew S this is a
guy you know he's CNBC but he's kind of
like their Golden Boy